[Musique]
run santé le salon de la santé et du
bien-être a ouvert ses portes au public
pour la toute première fois ce vendredi
20 mai au parc des expositions de saint
denis parmi les nombreux exposants
présents pendant les trois jours du
salon difficile de rater le stand du
département de la réunion partenaire de
l'événement le département est présent
aujourd'hui parce que nous sommes au
coeur de la compétence du département à
travers la prévention santé notamment le
département at intervient avec
différents niveaux en matière de santé
donc il était naturel que nous soyons
présents dans ce salon pour remarquer et
valoriser les actions que nous menons
que ce soit avec la pmi et là nous
sommes sur un stand de massage des bébés
c'est un lieu qui permet de créer le
lien avec les parents d'apporter un
mieux-être enfants et des tables et à la
relation entre nos professionnels et les
parents qui en ont bien besoin mais il
ya aussi bien d'autres prestations que
nous mettons en place la prévention des
addictions les différentes actions que
nous menons pour le ces pour les
personnes âgées les différents services
aux personnes plus âgées qui existe
depuis des années bref nous sommes
présents aux différents arrive de la vie
et nous voulons valoriser ses papiers
nombreux sont les réunionnais à faire
une halte au stand ce vendredi parmi eux
des enfants la collectivité leur a
réservé un accueil tout particulier avec
des ateliers coloriage santé dentaire un
parcours motricité ou encore un atelier
massage pour bébé
alors aujourd'hui je propose un atelier
massage bébé mais un atelier de
découverte donc on va recevoir un groupe
de quatre couples parents enfants et ça
va être vraiment une découverte du
massage parlé un petit peu des bienfaits
est prise il est de faire aussi qui est
un échange entre les parents pour qu'ils
puissent voilà discuter de toutes les
questions qui
leur trotte dans la tête si les
marmailles y trouveront leur compte les
agents et partenaires du département ont
également pensé aux plus grands avec un
moment de détente et de découverte des
thermes de cilaos un espace dédié au
planning familial ou encore un stand
réservé aux aidants familiaux
beaucoup de personne en fait ne se
reconnaissent pas en tant qu'aidant
disent qu'ils est en fait une personne
âgée une personne handicapée le font de
manière bénévole ne sont pas forcément
rémunéré était une prise en charge en
fait qui se fait quotidiennement quelque
fois difficilement donc c'est important
faite pour les pour nous d'être présent
aujourd'hui pour les aidants sache que
là ils existent qui sont des personnes
qui sont essentiels au maintien des
personnes dépendantes à domicile et que
nous proposons des solutions
d'accompagnement que ce soit de manière
collective ou individuelle
l'objectif pour le département
sensibiliser et éduquer le public sur
les différents dispositifs dédiés au
bien être et à la santé parfois méconnus
comme le dispositif ses amis or
aujourd'hui par une représentation c'est
hier que la kabylité conclusion d'un
accord militaire fusion c'est la carte
qui remplace
la carte d'invalidité priorités et
stationnement à l'heure d'aujourd'hui il
ya énormément de personnes qui ne savent
pas que
la cni existe on est là justement pour
les renseigner et acquise et le maximum
d'informations situé au centre du hall
principal de la nordev le département et
ses différents partenaires vous donne
rendez vous au stand 56 jusqu'au
dimanche 22 mai pour cette première
édition du salon de la santé et du
bien-être
[Musique]
m